let's do this
sonic the hedgehog spun his way onto the
silver screen releasing two very
successful blockbusters pleasing young
and old fans alike but who's voicing
these characters to success we're taking
you down a quick path of all the voices
and characters of the sonic the hedgehog
films
number one we think if anything's got to
be done right in a live action sonic
film it's got to be his personality and
who else better than ben schwartz to
take on the title character he's no
stranger to voice acting with a slew of
animated appearances his first being
disney's turbo as skidmark but once the
blue hedgehog landed in his repertoire
he was excited to give fans what they
wanted it's so fun to dive into the
mythology and to give the fans more of
what they want in terms of physical
movement he had an easier time than most
of the cast just keeping his voice in
tip-top shape number two who wasn't
excited for calling o'shaughnessy to
return to the classic role of tales we
certainly were it is an honor to finally
meet you sonic her impressive voice
acting resume extends from anime to
classic video game franchises top
credits go towards her work as the voice
of tales from the video games instantly
gaining approval from the die hard
fanbase with such a large attachment to
the character it was no surprise that
director jeff fowler wanted her to play
the titular role again and she was all
in to return to the mic for the flying
fox fighting alongside a version of
sonic that she's never met
number three idris elba has got the
voice for voice acting we've witnessed
his career span across multiple genres
from tv comedies to action blockbuster
films you're no match for me
surprisingly though he's kind of just
gotten into the whole voice actor
industry obtaining his first animated
role in disney zootopia and just working
his way up from there eventually
grabbing the title role of one of
sonic's nemesis knuckles elba felt eager
to take on the gig but really didn't
want to disappoint fans we felt he
nailed his interpretation and is
certainly a hand in punching this film
to the top of the box office i love
knuckles he's just like
straight to the point
number four this actor needs no
introduction he's funny-faced his way
into fans hearts over the past couple of
decades the bigger the ego the bigger
the mustache
jim carrey's cartoonish persona on
screen has always brought him
opportunities to get even more zany on
set but for him to take the role of dr
robotnik well it took quite the
convincing from his grandson to finally
concede to filmmakers requests i started
playing with my grandson who humiliated
me constantly all those losses really
helped mold his vision of the character
and really lost him a lot of money
apparently i i get angry i put money in
the swear jar
number five actor james marston rocks
his role as the adopted father of sonic
a title his character earned by taking
in the little alien as his own with
ample experience working alongside cgi
co-stars this was just another walk in
the park for him i mean the first movie
was me and sonic or me in a tennis ball
he's been able to maintain a great
relationship with schwartz although not
directly acting alongside him number six
tikka sumter upgraded her role to the
action hero in the sequel now
interacting with cgi a lot more she
found it to be a little strange yeah
just for the characters you know it was
somebody else on set we didn't get to
talk to the knuckles on set giving all
that emotion to a couple of golf balls
on sticks may just have made her a
seasoned improvisational actress you got
it you kind of you know got the gist of
it number seven like her on-screen
sister natasha rothwell didn't do much
in the first film but now that she got
her desires fulfilled she had a very
exhilarating time working with her cgi
counterparts a weird thing to be
looking earnestly at a tennis ball she
recalls the lengthy filming experience
performing multiple takes from different
angles just for vfx artists to
realistically add sonic and friends to
the scene
number 8 adam pally's awkward persona
fits right in as the cop sidekick wade
whipple and being one of the biggest
sonic video game fans this was a dream
role for him sega genesis was very
popular in my house he claims director
jeff balor is the one who sold all the
improvisational work but knowing adam he
was just given the freedom to shine next
to his cg actors jeff knows exactly what
he's doing and he's he's thought about
it number nine the comedic duo of a film
always needs a sidekick straight man he
recalls having the same experiences with
the vfx as his co-stars really only
harping on acting alongside his hero
maybe the obsession for working with
carrie just made his performance much
more believable
it's weird it's tough to put into words
with what that means number 10 one
character that has stayed true
throughout the ventures of sonic was his
own mentor longclaw voiced by donna j
folks she didn't have much to do in the
first film but her role in the second is
extremely crucial for sonic to succeed
in his quest we are graced with the
beloved voice actors of these films and
really got to know a lot of them through
their voices and on-screen characters do
you have any objections to the voice
casting of these movies we'd love to
know leave a comment below